hello everybody my name is janae flager
i'm the chief medical scientist for
microsoft research based up out of our
cambridge lab and this is my sincere
pleasure to host nubar atheian to
discuss the topic of emerging innovation
at the research summit this year
nubar is a distinguished entrepreneur
life science leader humanitarian and
somebody i've personally looked up to
for a number of years and it's my
sincere pleasure and my thanks to nubar
and his team for for joining us uh this
afternoon
uh newborn today i think we'll be
exploring a number of areas and learn
about the experiences that have shaped
you
your mission to improve the human
condition through science
and my say thanks again to you for for
taking the time to join us
personally i find your pers your story
absolutely fascinating and your personal
story seems to be something that's
completely central to your approach
around innovation
i wonder if you could share with this
audience a little bit of a story about
yourself and what's led you into the
health industry
well first generate thanks for the kind
words and introduction and uh it's a
pleasure to be able to have this uh
conversation with you today
um you know i think as as in many people
i'm sure you end up doing what you're
doing and then you realize that there
were things that moved you in that
direction although you're less conscious
about them
uh as that's happening and so it's only
after a period of time that some of the
moving kind of forces
appear
and so i think in my case
i do believe at this point that the
degree to which i tend to
be comfortable being uncomfortable and
being outright afraid
um the degree to which i'm
less accepting of
conformity and and kind of um
conventional wisdom and am willing to
risk uh you know sounding
dumb or unreasonable in order to make
new discoveries all of those things i
think are rooted in somewhat the past
that i've lived you know i i grew up uh
in lebanon in the middle east uh
basically saw a civil war for a portion
of
of of my life
um escaped and
re you know my father my mother rerouted
us in montreal canada i'd never seen
snow before let alone you know kind of
the culture
and without really knowing it as a
teenager kind of got accustomed to
being you know rootless essentially and
you might say well that can't be a good
thing but it turns out that if you're
going to live a life of
innovation or i'd call it extreme
innovation
in a funny way roots are not that useful
because if you want to keep planting
your roots in the future
among the things that that
prevents that is having deeply planted
roots in the past and by dent of my
personal history whether it's in my
lifetime or even the my family's history
which for generations has been
unfortunately
in various ways chased out of where we
where we lived uh probably
the disadvantage that that represented
ended up being an advantage to what i do
today because i'm less looking for the
kind of stability you get by doing
things you're supposed to know or doing
things you've done before
uh so yeah that those are the thoughts
at least that
over the past few years i've come to
think about the previous 30 years of my
journey
amazing and if you take all of that
you've done
engineering
biotech and now you you're the head of
an organization called flagship
pioneering i'd love perhaps you could
share with us taking those experiences
what led you into healthcare in
particular and could you tell us also a
little bit about flagship pioneering
well sure so so i ended up entering kind
of the field of biology as a graduate
student i had an undergraduate degree
from from mcgill university in in
montreal where i grew up ultimately in
chemical engineering and chemical
engineers in the prior century
had really been the basis for the
petrochemical industry
and many of its derivative products and
and generally dealt with chemistry
and in the early 80s when i when i
studied
there
the kind of only new cutting edge thing
uh that was happening was the beginnings
of what became known as biotechnology
and and and of course this was a
scientific endeavor in the first place
but since people wanted to make products
the closest thing to biological products
were chemical products or so we thought
and so the industry started using the
technologies
of producing chemicals at large scale to
try to make proteins which of course was
a ill-fated attempt because these are
quite different
materials and quite different properties
but nobody knew that so i ended up
getting drawn to that challenge again
being a little bit out of the the
comfort zone of a chemical engineer and
i came to mit to do a phd in in what was
a brand new program called biochemical
engineering i was the first graduate of
that of that center at mit in 1987 and
that planted me firmly in whatever bio
and chemical engineers would do um and
and but but interestingly that what got
me into healthcare uh beyond just that
is that
i was less interested in making large
quantities of things than understanding
the molecular mechanism of these
machines
you know most things that an engineer
engineers are man-made
and there is a portion of
engineering which is usually called
reverse engineering which is
other people reverse engineering what
man-made
but in nature
you don't have that man-made presumption
and yet you need to reverse engineer so
you can understand the mechanism of this
you know complex multiple interacting
parts machine and so i was drawn to that
my phd involved work in that area and
i've in one way pursued that for the
following 35 years
in one way or the other either by making
better technologies and tools by which
to do it or
to use the then newly understood
mechanisms to make better drugs or
better
uh even agricultural products or
nutritional products all places where
this kind of nature derived complexity
either guides
uh the the designs that you then use or
the something that you need to fix still
having understood what's going on
it's almost a beautiful segue it seems
to
some of the processes that have led you
to then think about the principles
behind flagship it seems i wonder if you
could tell our audience a little bit
around flagship pioneering i wonder how
many of them are aware of flagship i i'm
almost certain everybody will know of
moderna but will they know about the
link between madonna and flagship and
perhaps perhaps you could share that
sure where you know well
there's a there's a fractal nature to
to
this kind of kind of organization in the
sense that every bit as much as
everybody knows about covet vaccines
but nobody knew about moderna
everybody now knows about moderna but
they don't know about flagship and of
course that's because
you know and it's it's all about kind of
what's the goose and what's the golden
egg at some level you know we
uh as an organization
set out to develop
back in 2000
institutional framework within which to
make
breakthrough innovations and create
companies to
to realize them to make them real
and and if you go back to the late 90s
let alone the fact that everybody was
infatuated with the internet and and
nobody really did much of this kind in
biotechnology although the genomic
sequence was being at least bit by bit
revealed at the time
the notion that you could
systematize
breakthroughs which is an offensive
thought i'm sure to the audience even
today
let alone
further systematize and professionalize
the act of conceiving and creating a
company around set breakthroughs
not around yet another version of the
same company that you're making with a
slight variant the notion that you could
systematize that first-in-kind companies
first-in-kind technologies
was was
kind of obnoxious enough that it was
interesting to me it was interesting to
other people that i could assemble
because it really was a scary scary
journey and and that's what we wanted to
undertake so
20 years later
um we in fact have at least the
beginnings of of an approach to making
breakthrough innovations we call this
emergent discovery uh and we've
described it a little bit happy to get
into it
uh here but basically that methodology
which involves making leaps and then
searching around where you've left too
as opposed to searching around where you
start
that plus a methodology by which we
think about a stage-gated way to produce
a company out of nothing
those are things that have
provided the
the let's say frameworks
that allow us to
create and launch
six to eight
totally new platform companies each year
uh operate currently some 50 plus
companies that are all founded based on
ip we've developed and so that's the
that's what flagship pioneering is it's
a if you will a company of companies but
a particular kind of companies and that
is ones that develop platforms that are
based on brand new science for
technology and have companies built
around them
and i would absolutely encourage people
who haven't made themselves familiar to
make themselves familiar with the
processes that you've described
i've been made aware of a range of hard
business review articles there's a ton
of information on your website and i
will take you up on your invitation of
maybe digging deeper into that process
around i think you describe it as
emergent innovation or emergent
discovery perhaps in a moment but i want
to come back to that notion of mindset
um that you've spoken about in the past
as well around what's the mindset that
you have to have
in order to
almost push away
the
standard approach to things and you've
spoken uh previously around this notion
of paranoid optimism i wonder if that's
one of the mindsets that you personally
have or the ones that you look for when
you're building out your team but what
are those mindsets that really are
required for flagship success and its
innovation process
well there's several things that i can
just very briefly mention
starting with the paranoid optimism part
yes for some 25 of the years that i've
worked um you know first time i had to
talk about these things
um was when i had done it a couple of
times and people wanted to
that forced me to describe things and i
always hated listening to people's
stories about how they started a company
because it almost seemed kind of like
you know random in the sense that they
were telling lessons but they had an n
of one i mean they had one example and i
thought what can i say that's a little
bit beyond that it's a bit more
repeatable
and and this notion of paradigm optimism
um is is one that really rose to the top
for me i was aware of andy grove's book
about the only the paranoid survivor i
remember when it came out i actually met
with him uh back in that time frame and
saw him give a talk
and and and i thought you know
paranoia enough isn't enough to do
something that's never been done before
because it's depressing uh and and
because you know that's usually the
psychological state you'll get into
um but but if it's if it's juxtaposed
with a more
daring exploratory mindset which is
optimism
optimism basically suppresses your
concerns paranoia heightens them and if
you can toggle between the two
simultaneously not you know kind of
being either optimistic or or paranoid
but simultaneously being a lot of each
that struggle
ends up causing you to be poised but
still action oriented right so if you're
not optimistic enough you just won't be
willing to make the leaps that it often
takes to do something truly novel if so
you're not paranoid enough you'll make
reckless leaps and not constantly be
re-evaluating and adjusting based on
real world evidence of what's going on
and so that that juxtaposition is an
important one but there are other
mindsets that i've come to view over the
years
more recently i've talked quite a bit
about this notion of an immigrant
mindset you know if you think about it
immigrants you don't have to be an
immigrant to have an immigrant mindset
but having an immigrant mindset is a
very important part in my view of being
innovative in the sense that if you
think about an immigrant who changes
countries either by force or by uh
aspiration wanting something better for
themselves
what what you find is somebody who is
unaccustomed to the to the
uh habits of where they end up barely
knows the language often doesn't take
anything for granted doesn't think
anything is old to them and is
constantly worried about the police or
the rules or the violating the law
they're just in this highly paranoid
state and they recognize that the first
order of business is to get out of a
survival mode just to survive and then
try to kind of proceed and so that
survivalistic mindset is really really
important but one of the things it does
is it actually helps you
take relatively more risk not less
because if you think things are owed to
you and if you think you're supposed to
kind of say authoritative you know kind
of believable things
you're not going to be in an immigrant
mindset you're going to be a a native
and and natives you know over time lose
their edge
as to
willingness to do the dirty work
willingness to to be willing to fail so
you know if you're an immigrant you
start out failing and your only better
alternative is once in a while succeed
if you're not and if you're not in that
mindset you actually expect to succeed
which is which is a disappointing state
to be in in my experience when you're
dealing with novelty and startups etc so
i think that's an important mindset as
well then the third mindset uh that i'll
just share
uh is this notion of how to deal with
dogma how to deal with expertise you
know when you're doing science when
you're doing technology
expertise matters a lot
and of course there's this notion that
experts
know a lot and that's true but what i've
observed over the years is that experts
know relatively little about the future
what they know a lot about is the
present and the imminent present the
imminent future that's the adjacent
future and in fact they over index with
their authoritative knowledge about that
such that if you actually ask an expert
about a breakthrough
actually their general orientation will
be to be highly skeptical especially if
it's contrary to what the conventional
wisdom is that's what dogma is all about
so i i've come to view
uh dogma as kind of a
form of intellectual gravity that's very
very hard to escape and so we're brought
up in academia in in in science in
general respecting the
the the the college of study that we're
in the area
of of study that we're in and people
generally don't say
unreasonable things because they'll be
chased out of that field and yet i would
argue and we'll come back to this that
most
real departures most real novel thoughts
start out being unreasonable by
definition otherwise they're not a
departure and and yet the rest of the
world whether it's nih grant proposals
or or corporate funding or venture
capital funding what is all that about
going and asking experts what they think
of your otherwise remote thought and
what are they going to say bad idea
won't work if it could work it would
have been done already and i really
don't think you should spend any money
on that so so that gravity brings you
right back to earth and it forces you to
find an ever
so differentiated tiny incremental thing
that people will bless on the one hand
and yet might give you the opportunity
to create value
so how you overcome that
is is kind of to make peace with the
fact that if you truly want to do things
that have not been done before you will
be attacked by definition by
dogma
amazing i mean the way that you and
you've clearly
had to hone in since i'm sure a number
of conversations over the last few years
around this articulation of mindsets and
it rings true to a lot of the work that
i'm personally doing and i'm sure a lot
of our audience is doing too
and when you think about breakthroughs i
i know you use the word but i know you
don't take it lightly
it sounds like flagship is designed to
not just think about one breakthrough
but multiple breakthroughs across
all multiple areas of healthcare and i
wonder if you wouldn't mind just sharing
some of that because the approach you
have something that i've read about
certainly um to systematize that seems
extraordinary actually the way that you
as i've heard it look at impossible
problems
and challenge people to even extend that
their thinking leveraging the tensions
that you've described would it be
possible just to talk a little bit about
those processes as you think through
that process to to from
uh the idea state to the the prototype
company to the scaled
company sure i'll i'll try to do that a
little bit and
it's always frustrating to the audience
because it's not enough but i would
encourage you
to kind of just look up and read more
about it because it's something that
often resonates with people but not in
its kind of formal formal way of
thinking about the steps involved in
doing it so you first have to start with
a
a change in belief system that that i
would argue
people should go and do their own
research about which is that i would
argue that most if not all breakthrough
innovations
start out life in a relatively ugly
you know kind of form
and that they're not they know they're
not born
beautiful they're not born functioning
and so if you're trying to find a
starting point that is already
in its full form a major breakthrough
that's an illusion so i have come to
believe
breakthrough innovations as being
largely an emergent act
i'll point out not to offend anyone but
including the work i've done
often what happens is the people who are
there when that emergent process ends up
with a beautiful outcome
that the people who are there at that
time take full credit for how it
happened and in fact describe it in ways
that are highly
uh um
revisionist not not in a malicious way
but rather in a rationalizing way i
always tell people
you know is what you're describing the
rationale for what you did or the
rationalization of what you did
rationalization has the benefit of
hindsight and i find that often the way
people describe innovations is by
knowing what the end of the movie looks
like and boy is that a different uh
experience than the way it actually
happens just my
observations over 35 years and i've met
hundreds of other people who've who've
engaged in in doing things that you know
defy gravity somewhat so first thing you
have to do is to kind of say you know
what so this is not a goal-based
activity this is not something that is
not designed you don't design a
breakthrough it emerges so if you
believe that the way we've come to think
about it is that there's two things you
need to think about
of the processes we know of that are say
emergent in nature that is a non-linear
combination of of the parts iteratively
ultimately give advantage
darwinian evolution is a damn good one
uh it's produced us it's produced most
of the life forms uh that all of the
life forms we know of all most of nature
and so and so if you look at what is
that that's basically just variation
selection and iteration if you take
those operators
and apply them to dna or any information
molecule you get
optimization you get improvement and
optimization of fit between the
environment that the entity is living in
and the entity itself
if you by the way do this in software
you'll get all sorts of you know machine
learning type generative algorithms that
create you know
beauty create novelty that is an
unexpected outcome of the steps you were
taking because it's truly emerging so we
knew that 20 years ago in fact i worked
on a company is what was called
affinover for many many years where we
used
evolutionary algorithms online to design
products of all kinds using consumer
feedback this was back in 2002 3 4 in
those time frames early days of internet
so why am i saying that we started using
that mindset for the kind of work we do
so i said there's two things one is that
but it turns out that if you apply that
to ideas that are proximal which you
could
you find yourself applying a powerful
emergent technique
in what is otherwise a commodity space
and you might say what do you mean by
commodity i would argue among the things
i wish i knew 25 years ago
is that adjacency oriented innovation
which i'll argue is what most
most of us do
adjacency oriented innovation is by
definition a rapidly commoditizing space
because incumbents
preoccupy it literally preoccupy it
it'll preoccupies them
venture capitalists occupy whatever is
left over because they want the
incumbents to buy out the companies
academia is because of the way science
is funded naturally occupying
adjacencies and gradually kind of
advancing them so the good news is you
can apply a new technique the bad news
is it's a really crowded space
so the part that was kind of rather a
departure even for us years into our
existence was the notion that what we
needed to do is to escape the adjacency
and so how do you do that and that kind
of you know for lack of better words
kind of maybe people think about it as a
leap of faith you need to be able to
leap you need to be able to
create hypotheses
of things that
could exist even though there's no proof
that they can actually happen and the
value that would derive from them if
only they existed and in the first
instance
gennade and this might be a little odd
to your audience it's purely an act of
imagination you know we can call it
brainstorming we can give it lots of
ideation there's a lot of euphemisms for
imagination it's just the imagination so
the beauty is if you have some
experience
and you're uninhibited
you should be able to imagine
things that don't yet exist you people
should have been able to imagine and i'm
sure they did the cloud of cloud
computing decades before what what
stopped people from imagining in fact
there's a whole field of literature
called science fiction that's all that
is is this reasonable descriptions of
possible futures well if you do that it
turns out in in the problem-solving
space or in a way you seek impact you
could imagine products you could imagine
underlying technologies and by the way
you have to keep yourself that's the
paranoia part realizing that it's not
real just because you could imagine it
but that gives you the ability to leap
and leap beyond where people are working
now now when you leap you'll end up with
some starting points that's the initial
hypothesis we do this maybe some 80 to
100 times a year we conduct these formal
explorations where we generate
hypothetical value propositions in
different aspects of health and
sustainability that have no basis in
current reality but they're the product
of this leaping
when you combine the two ideas of
leaping and then using darwinian
evolution to search locally and iterate
iterate iterate so you might say where's
the selection function come from so the
selection function comes from lots of
discussions with experts by the way
non-experts even better
people who have done startups people are
in large companies people in academia so
what we do is we take ill-formed
imaginary descriptions of future
realities
we expose them to it's the best we can
do the current set of thoughts about
what what why it's a bad idea by the way
experts are by far the best way to
rapidly figure out what's bad about your
idea they're like professionals at that
and that saves you a lot of time you
don't have to read all the papers you
don't have to repeat every experiment
they know why it's a bad idea so we use
that
and ultimately what happens is that
without doing a single experiment you
can a priori rule out a whole bunch of
versions of what you're trying to claim
could be valuable even because there's
some fatal flaw in them
leaving behind a few
that
aren't known not to work but if they
work they could be valuable
that is the step that leads us to then
form a small what we call protocompany
and go in the lab and do reduction to
practice experiments which is our last
art by the way you know patents are all
about reduction to practice but nobody
actually reduces to practice things
because they don't use imagination
they use more like discovery or design
as mental tools but here what we do is
we imagine we test as much as we can dry
experiments discussions and then we'll
go in and say can you actually even do
this and if i map this on to moderna
some 11 years ago summer of 2010 we
wondered what if you could actually
inject an information molecule into the
body and have the body make just about
any protein we wanted that was the
formative question we knew that there
were different ways you of molecules
that could kind of give this information
but none of them had been used as drugs
before and so long before we did
experiments we had to ask ourselves okay
well if so what would you do where would
you inject it how would how to get into
cells how much protein would it make is
it the right protein what diseases would
you apply to you can ask all those
questions without knowing whether you
could do it to begin with and that's
some of the thinking that we've used to
allow ourselves to leap
then to
search for descendants of the original
bad idea to come up with better ideas
then to reduce it to practice if it's
possible if it's not then it's really
easy for a small amount of money we can
kind of park the experiment and see if
becomes relevant in the future and once
in a while you get breakthroughs
amazing and i love what you said about
almost the practice of imagination
there's one of the one of the books
behind me that i carried in my uh pocket
throughout all of my uh residency as it
were or my house jobs in the uk and i
never looked at the first page all i
ever used it for was to look at all the
clinical pathways the first science
sentence of that book says medicine is a
practice and an exercise of the
imagination um because actually the
essence of medicine
is in my mind something that gives
people hope it may not ever deliver a
cure
but actually everything that we're doing
is a little bit sci-fi it has never been
done before and everything that happened
during the pandemic was rapid
translation of science into outcomes for
society
and everything that we'll do from here
on in will continue to exercise that
imagination in my mind
and if i was to give you a crystal ball
newborn and think about the next five to
ten years what do you think are the
the what are your thoughts just on the
future of health over the next five to
ten years what are the the big
challenges that you're in particular
interested that society finds solutions
for
yes is the answer to that question
there's no there's no shortage of both
solutions and problems i should say a
couple of quick things
that come to mind that i haven't
mentioned before
one is that in this type of
of what this by the way everything i've
described is why we use the word
pioneering it's you know unfortunately
innovation is a commodity term in and of
itself now so we kind of had to say okay
well what is what is first of its kind
innovation what is what is something if
when you try to
um you know bring forward a brand new
value pool uh that people have not
tapped into before and we call that
pioneering in the in as a nod to the
ecological definition of pioneering
which which there is one in the
dictionary which is kind of the
organisms that first go into a barren
place and make it livable colonizable so
it's the first to colonize and we kind
of thought okay if there are these
barren places of value if you can find
it first and access it first then you
also get to set up the rules for how
it's how it develops and certainly in
mrna technology we've done that in many
of the microbiome fields we've also done
that having started in first companies
and there's many many other places where
we've played this initial kind of
colonizing role
so i i say that because
as you go as you look forward uh the
second concept that we also haven't
talked about which is really really
important in everything we do is this
notion of of platforms we call these bio
platforms and and while this is a
well-known concept in the software or
app kind of based industries or service
uh in in the modern kind of shared
economy where there's all sorts of
platforms that enable multiple things to
be to to be enabled at the same time
in the in in the biotechnology field
platforms are thought of as technologies
you know kind of sequencing or pcr but
that's not what we mean by platforms
well mima platform is a common set of
capabilities that have not existed
before but that could directly produce
many many many products and so mrna was
a platform we did not develop it as a
product we developed it as a platform
the reason i say that is as we sit here
today there are literally a dozen
totally unprecedented platforms that
we're developing and others are as well
that i think will create whole new
branches of medicine
that either will allow us to go where
drugs have not been able to go before or
will will create a whole new modality of
medicine even if somebody has done
something before that gives huge
advantages either in ineffectiveness or
or in in in in time to develop etc so
there's one set of futures that will be
enabled by new and new platforms and new
and new capabilities and and that is
working very very effectively uh as we
as we speak the other area uh which
which you're kind of inviting me to
speculate on is you know what can be
done that's truly disruptive in
healthcare and for me
the the the at least the big
uh promised or unpromised land i guess i
call it that right now is
uh what we've kind of been calling
preemptive medicine or health security
and and and the whole idea there is that
um you know today we have medicine
focused on disease forward
we have generally wellness
and and fitness things that are
trying to preserve health
and in between
there's there's really nothing i mean
there's supplements and the like that
that are considered unfortunately
not considered in the way the same way
as medicine is and therefore most people
don't really know whether to rely on it
or not
but but what's changed is in the last 20
years a lot of the molecular techniques
that have been developed in service of
disease-based health care
but has never been applied upstream
where there isn't a quote known disease
so we've been trying to focus on this is
even before the pandemic but of course
the pandemic has made it a bigger issue
at least in the infectious disease side
but i think this applies everywhere that
i think that that in the future we're
going to have to use the advanced
science and technology we have to
identify pre-disease states
across every single disease area
and by molecularly characterizing them
also intervene at a pre-disease state
and and these will not be treatments
because you don't have a disease
therefore they will not be
necessarily regulated as drugs because
that's not what they are
but
they do for a subset of the population
that is in a risk profile that's already
advancing to a disease
we need to intervene then and we see
this in certainly neurological disorders
where clearly the more advanced versions
are extremely hard to deal with by the
way cancer where most everything's been
done for late stage cancer because much
easier due to trials but yet the problem
is much much bigger upstream so
creating a field where
medicine becomes preemptive there's this
whole notion of prevention and vaccines
but i think preemption kind of says some
of this is
is is going to happen but if we could
delay it
alter its form
and and deal with it before you get into
the disease treatment
mindset you know i sometimes say you
know if you turn on the tv you can't go
one minute before seeing an ad that is
embellishing a patient journey
if it was up to me i'd rather embellish
the pre-patient journey i'd rather stay
on the pre-patient ride for as long as i
could and then become a patient
but unfortunately there's no such thing
as a pre-patient you're well and then
you're given a death sentence i mean i'm
exaggerating and obviously you you know
this field extremely well so i am at
least
imagining dreaming of hoping for and
working on together with the whole
organization at flagship a set of
applications of our technologies and
platforms
upstream
and hoping that by use cases by examples
and impact we can get regulators and
certain countries that are thinking in
advance to begin to adopt some of these
and realize finally
that the best way to to reduce cost of
healthcare provisioning is to move
upstream we know this with vaccines they
are by far the most cost-effective
health interventions we have and yet up
until this pandemic we had very few of
them they were a commodity business
nobody wanted to be in it and we'll see
what happens after this after the
pandemic but even beyond vaccines
vaccines to me are the tip of an iceberg
of saying it's too late when you're sick
we gotta deal with these things upstream
fantastic and as as you talk a lot of
that through
the notion of the question around data
data access this notion of not just the
medical data but the social determinants
of health data your genomics your
individual behaviors everything that
could be defined as preemption kind of
comes in and as i think that through i
wonder what as maybe as in terms of
closing remarks just your thoughts or
indeed recommendations to the tech
sector in general and how you think the
tech sector should be thinking about
their role in supporting life science
organizations be it flagship be it large
biofarmer and others do you have any
thoughts around what the tech sectors
should be doing or indeed be doing
differently in the future
well i mean clearly the health sector is
is super data rich
and and and is is not as
advanced in its digital disruption if
you will as many other sectors a lot of
reasons for that that are practical
some of them are legal
practical meaning different systems
incompatibilities etc but i'd say if you
get into the kind of discovery research
life science side of this it's even more
the case that the techniques we're
developing to make measurements
are producing
results that especially when integrated
are completely incomprehensible to
humans
and i think we're well in an age
where without artificial intelligence
machine learning approaches
we will literally
be
ignoring
euphemism for that is abstracting the
data uh in order to make sense of it so
the human sensibility is going to be
offended by the amount of data we can
generate and and we'll try to kind of
force it into compliance by only
focusing on the things that interest us
as opposed to leaving it intact and
using approaches that can kind of give
us some level of patterns to focus on
versus just what we what we decided was
going on i say that because i think
we're just in the beginning of that and
and certainly that's a pervasive aspect
of what we're developing new companies
around this several of our companies in
the last two three years are entirely
based on things that but for machine
learning approaches and some data we
could not ever think of doing and i
think that's going to teach us things
about disease mechanisms and pathways we
didn't know about we're discovering
entirely new states of cells in our
bodies that nobody knew existed we're
discovering completely new proteins
we're discovering things you know we're
discovering viruses in our bodies that
nobody knew existed and you can't catch
them without having a massive amount of
data
that you then start looking for certain
things in
by identifying certain patterns that
you've seen elsewhere
indicate the presence of this let alone
generating proteins we have we have a
whole whole platform we've developed
over many years to de novo from scratch
generate proteins of arbitrary function
arbitrary binding ability so all of this
is in the future
and i think the tech companies
who are on the one hand very accustomed
to handling and and and processing large
amounts of data and extracting meaning
from them
are going to have to figure out how to
make that useful
that capability useful and of course
it's attractive to do it in healthcare
simply because it just looks like
consumer data at some level it's a
different kind of data as you get more
into the science i think people kind of
have gotten a little bit nervous about
it because they feel like they're at a
disadvantage not knowing the biology but
i think we're at a time where the
biology will give way to the data
science because it's again beyond human
comprehension at least that's what i
believe and it's going to have to be
bilingualism
not one dominant language then kind of
serving the other and and that's that's
what the next decade will be about
newborn my sincere thanks to you i wish
we had more time and i'm i'm sure i
could go on for hours having this
masterclass with you and learning from
you and and your and your wisdom and my
thanks to you on behalf of the research
summit community here i look forward to
hopefully connecting with you in person
in due course and every best wish to
everything that you're trying to do
within flagship uh and all the
humanitarian causes that i knew
how you somehow find the time to do in
your spare time so thank you again look
i i appreciate the discussion i will
caveat everything you just said by the
warning that i told you that most of
what we work on are things we know
nothing about you should include the
last 30 minutes as things have talked
about that i really don't know much
about but they really should be rather
invitations for the audience to think
differently so master class you know if
if anything it's master class in in in
improvisation not in knowledge i don't
think this is a yet a masterful kind of
field but i hear you and i appreciate
the the chance to share some thoughts
and hopefully people will have their own
thoughts and and and start iterating
around them
thank you again